[Music]
Los Angeles come on Hollywood that's
what I like to hear what's up my fellow
Jedi I'm Greg Miller and today we're
talking Star Wars Jedi fallen order
we've been waiting so you can like know
what we're talking about Star Wars yeah
we've been waiting so long for details
on this game I can't believe it can you
believe in LA and we're finally here to
help us get things started we've got the
head of respawned Vince Zampella and the
director of Star Wars Jedi fallen
ordered Stig as mucin everybody give it
up for Vincent stay come on
[Applause]
how you doing good give me the hug [ __ ]
let's get it going
yeah yeah please keep it co and they're
making a Star Wars game guys welcome to
EA play thank you great welcome how are
you feeling right now no pressure your
zermat announced maybe one of the
biggest if not the biggest games of your
lives
hello let's dig answer this one you're
supposed to answer this off script so
yeah we're totally off they gave me
cards that was so awesome to be here hey
play it see three it's Star Wars yeah
and it doesn't really get any bigger
than that yeah this is something that's
stick and I have been envisioning for
years to see it come to life and be able
to show you guys 15 minutes of gameplay
today
uncut alright alright
so everybody's anxious to see what this
15 and this is going to be yeah for
somebody watching right now who's just a
FIFA fan they don't know anything what
is happening what is this game all about
Vince this is a single-player
action-adventure game set post set post
order 66 after the events in episode 3
what all the Jedi were hunted down well
that on all when the Jedi were
contaminated
so Stig that's the nutshell of the
entire game what are we about to see
where are we at in the game right now
for context okay so Cal's like this
takes place maybe about 3 hours into the
game okay so Cal's built himself up he's
not a lowly Padawan anymore but he's not
a full Jedi yet sure
like Vince said this is unedited we had
one of our star players Blair
this is an axe for playthrough okay so
we're gonna see some really cool stuff
he practiced a few times two or three
Blair two or three point two or three
dozen it takes place on Kashyyyk
Milwaukee wiki planning of course and
Cal's on a mission to restart the Jedi
Order and it takes him here to Kashyyyk
and the wiki's have been enslaved by the
Empire was basically siphoning the
planet for all its resources to build up
the Imperial war machine got it alright
so I brought up my phone not to be rude
of course it wouldn't be Greg Miller if
I didn't look at the twitch chat and
yeah they are all through with us
talking they'd like to see the game
we've gone on long enough we're not
gonna drown it's two feet well let's
roll
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
over here
[Music]
[Music]
Imperial SAP refinery lies dead ahead
once the empire wall with tree sap
another good the refiners happened to a
powerful compound and they're rushing to
expand production
[Music]
we have to stop them muster play we
don't know their in-game when they
spread themselves through this map we
have a coffin but these refineries
double as brutal prison camps use those
cutters to create a distraction and luck
you take your lightsaber and freedom
walkies inside we need help to stop the
Empire understood watch yourself in
there
you hear them saying use the help
breathe lovely
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
over there one of the cutters are doing
[Music]
gonna need to get through here
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
think you can help me beat
[Music]
plant beetle they're coming through the
wall
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you sure you want to plug into this
thing okay
[Music]
[Music]
this thing
[Music]
just wanted to turn that cutter on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
patrolled the base got another breach
down here some kind of wedding
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I just heard from the captain they're
coming
[Music]
[Applause]
Jedi will be here any minute and our
reinforcements every good sir the fewer
distractions the better
[Music]
you can
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
help
[Music]
leave slices
guards
[Music]
for you
[Music]
visitation is not
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
little boy
guys congratulations that looks pretty
awesome Thanks I have a million
questions and I know we're short on time
as always I want to point out though in
the twitch chat Gwyn 96 says that's
freaking cool
but he didn't use frickin um how does it
feel - I think deliver right like did
you guys liked it right I think the
twitch chat there's a lot of people who
liked it like what does that feel like
to finally show this game oh it's great
I mean being involved with this teams
you know staking this team have done an
amazing job they put so much of
themselves into this game to be able to
be involved in something like this is
just you know dream come true yeah
agreed huge shout out to the team
everybody everybody who busted the bots
on the demo but also the whole game the
whole game is coming together right now
so it's amazing feeling I'm just so
proud to be up here and I I hope that uh
Star Wars fans understand that we're
really doing our best to try to honor
the brand I mean I think from now on
we'll stop whenever you want to clap
from you platform I think that's pretty
evident from it in I like when we
introduce our talking about the fact
that this is a skilled person playing it
right we all see it we think it looks
awesome what are we missing by not
having our hands on the controllers like
what what what is the lightsabers feel
like um it's fantastic yeah like because
it looks like it's got weight to it and
throwing it and catching it right like
that's the impact I think I want from it
absolutely yeah I mean it's it's really
satisfying michaei MIT self it's like
it's thoughtful combat as stig likes to
call it it's it's what you saw was a
really good player yeah right so you
over there give out autographs after
this panel so you can block parry
deflect like we want the combat to feel
really good for people to go in and be
able to like be part of that and size up
the enemies when things
feel right and it's it feels really good
yeah it's it's also it's about the enemy
arrangements as well like what enemies
were putting you up against and how you
go in and use your tools yeah take them
down but it's not just lightsabers it's
the force as well sure well that's part
of it you were talking to me last night
about it right this thoughtful combat
and the idea that when I watched the
demo initially my thought was oh these
are KN animations right I'm doing a
force grab and stabbing the guy and
that's all I hit r1 and that happen
that's not that well it's all freeform
so like you can go back in and replay
things and do it differently or you
absolutely and actually the enemies
react to each other in different ways
you saw the flame troopers fighting
against the spiders you could says by
standard and just kind of watch that
fight if you wanted to yeah but you're
not gonna get any skill behind sivan
either it's fun to watch sometimes but
it is a lot more fun to play you talk
about the skill points are those going
into the force abilities yeah so we're
gonna have the classic abilities we're
gonna have push-pull we've got what we
call force flip which is essentially
double jump which is nice because that's
something that makes sense in Star Wars
a Jedi actually doing a double jump but
we have one unique expression of the
force that you saw in there which is
slow which is a little bit of the glue
between force push and pull yeah what
that was awesome I think I thought you
couldn't top my favorite moment in the
demo right where you come around the
corner grab the stormtrooper force pull
stormtrooper stabbed them but when you
four stole the structure and walked him
in yes that was pretty cool that's one
of my favorite but I think the first
time I saw that I freaked out a little
you actually said it better be in the
demo yeah well you did it you delivered
tell me about the enemies we are seeing
there right because that's one of those
things I feel like we're talking a lot
about seeing things a lot about is we're
running through the environment you had
different things you had your normal
stormtroopers yet non normal
stormtroopers yeah and this is just a
small portion of the game by the way so
there's a lot more that we have in here
saying that isn't the entire game that
is not know we got we got our classic
stormtroopers we've got the scout
troopers who you saw equipped with kind
of melee charged weapon we've got the
flame troopers but we also have the
purge troopers whose task is basically
hunt Jedi
yeah soften them up before the
inquisitors come in in like we're seeing
right here right like this is bad that's
the bird exactly like so new that the
team created
in to the Star Wars he created just that
one banded to charge Jordan did the
concept good job Jordan so we're going
through and you have these new
stormtroopers you have your fire
troopers you have one of my favorite
droids of all time coming back the K X
and then making me fight him yeah why
would you do that I don't do know trust
me you do I do
yeah well then talk about the other star
of this 15 minute demo right
the new droid bb-8 is right there Thank
You PT 1 he's adorable as I'm sure you
know I immediately want him as a
backpack so just a heads up if you're
talking to be alive sensing Department
that I um
we can make what does he do in the game
right excuse me we're hosting a man keep
it down over there what what are the
traits what are we using as is he just
flare is am I using him for dealings
like story-wise he counts companion yeah
explore droid which is perfect his cows
on this mission check for survival
that's taken them to all these savage
planets bTW sounds for buddy droid one
which is a that's respawn notice the
wall running this game definitely
inspired bTW I ended up sticking yeah
one of the cool factoids is he's his
voice is authored by the legendary Ben
Burtt oh nice who did all the sounds son
main sound designer in the original
trilogy and yeah but you can hack doors
computers as we saw in there I'm just
scanned some stuff there yep okay
environment for like environmental
storytelling learn more lore about the
planet I saw him shooting out health
packs if that a can't animation after a
fight is it a button I'm hitting its
player input okay whenever you walk down
on it whatever they want be well Jack to
stim pack okay there's a limited amount
I'll find more over the course of the
game and your act
in that moment you're defenseless so you
got to choose wisely when you're gonna
do it okay
um we've talked we've seen the gameplay
without spoiling stuff for me what's
going on in this story like obviously
Callan yeah I thought it was gonna be
way weaker as a Jedi you know just tell
me the whole story
what a to be Stig how's it go full-stop
I can't believe I've gone this long in
the panel without asking is Watteau in
this game I can't say tag Watteau 2019
I'll be retweeting them all after this
panel thank you very much but let's go
through the story outside of water
should be in it well you know stories a
really big deal deal to us we've created
this with the Lucasfilm it's we got to
keep a really tight lip on it so I can't
I don't really sorry I mean yeah that's
it
okay I know one of the things a lot of
people have been asking right I'd put up
stuff on Instagram saying hey give me
questions community wanted to know this
is Star Wars Canon right you slowly can
okay totally legit okay into the real
Cal's a real character yeah soft sup
sorry right there he's he's uh you know
obviously part of this Star Wars
universe Cyr cows mentor yeah they're
all gonna live in other places
okay that's great Vince how's that feel
no pressure
it feels great yeah yeah I mean we have
[Music]
I said I'm just like shocked to be up
here I'm in like I know it's big deal to
work with me but it's okay we've been
talking about this for like ten years
yeah the other big community question
I've seen a lot is it's a Star Wars game
in Star Wars in the past have allowed us
to go light or dark is that a choice
here no okay well why not
because no I think it goes back to the
fact that Cal's authentic yeah and he
has to fill a certain role so we can be
used in other places yeah this is a Jedi
story well that's the thing I appreciate
the most that you guys are coming in and
telling a story right like I think
that's why so many of us are excited for
it is the idea that this is a Star Wars
story that you guys have something to
tell something to say and a lot of walls
to run on
Vince's dick anything you want to say to
the fans before we let you go means just
thanks for the support the the the
energy here is great that's fantastic
fantastic online like everyone's
reaction is fantastic amazing amazing
it's the team badass thank you guys I go
to your hard work now we just have to
finish can't wait to bring it to you
guys there's so much more that you
haven't seen yet I can't wait to show
you believe it or not there's so much
more there is more at the Microsoft
conference tomorrow that's right
Vince steak thank you so much for coming
out November 15th can't come soon enough
for those of you here at EA play the
respawn team has brought even more
gameplay for you to check out over the
Star Wars Jedi fall in order theater and
for those of you at home extended I was
supposed to do a bit for those of you at
home you will stay tuned for apex
legends yeah we're looking for
thank you for the yeah like that's the
corniest joke I put in this thing no
one's gonna like everybody I'm Greg
Miller thanks everyone for watching we
got more EA play for you now
[Applause]